bonjour je m'appelle Mathias j'ai 21 ans
je recherche dans le domaine du
secrétariat plutôt dans l'administration
aussi et pourquoi pas on accueil je
recherche dans la zone Nord Est
Saint-Denis jusqu'à Saint-Benoît je suis
diplômée dans baccalauréat STG
spécialités Ressources Humaines j'ai
fait une première année de licence AES
administration économie sociale j'ai
voulu l'expérience professionnelle dans
le secrétariat de la société multimark
auto j'ai appris à gérer les stocks
accueillir les clients et gérer les
ventes par ailleurs j'ai des expériences
en tant que vendeuse en libre-service
j'accueillais les clients gérer les
commandes et faisait les caisses je
maîtrise aussi le tien informatique
tout ce qui est word excel powerpin je
suis motivée souriante dynamique et
j'aime le travail en équipe je suis
disponible et motivée pour tout
renseignement complémentaire n'hésitez
pas à me contacter